welcome back to 8701
we have seen in the previous video how
neutrinos can acquire mars
when they have mask their weak
eigenstate is not equal to their
massaging state
so we observe the same mixing as we have
seen in the quark sector
so let's review this a little bit so
you know just starting from two neutrino
generations
we can write the flavoring states we are
a mixing of mass eigenstates if we do
this
with a simple matrix we find that there
is one angle
[Music]
used for the rotation of the mass
eigenstate into the flavoring states
all right so we can at some time d0
write our neutrino or mule neutrino as a
combination of the one
and two massaging states if we then have
this neutrino
evolve with time we see that
the relative contribution of the one and
two mass eggs that actually changes
so if we do that so we see we find some
time evolution
if we then ask ourselves what is the
probability
um that you know we start from a
neural neutrino that we actually find in
an interaction
electron neutrino through this mixing of
mass eigenstates
we can calculate this probability
just by squaring the amplitudes um if we
do this we just
use this part here and we find that
there's a cosine
e2 minus e1 term
all right good so let's analyze this a
little bit further
we know that the masses need to be small
so one thing we can also do here
is do a taylor expansion of our energy
and then just rewrite the term if we
then
analyze this some more we find that
the oscillation probability simply
depends
on the mass difference squared
the length of distance the neutrino had
time from t 0
to oscillate and the energy of the
neutrino
so this is fantastic because now by
studying the not
the the probability for a neutrino to
change its flavor
we can infer the mass differences of two
states
this is fantastic i should add here that
in this case
in this formula the length is given
in meters the energy
is given oops unit of the energy mav
and the mass difference is in ev
otherwise equation doesn't make sense
good
so again we have um seen if we start
from
a two neutrino kind of model two
neutrino flavor model
that the experimental parameters of of
interest here are the lengths
of distance from the neutrino source to
the detector
from the place where we generate a
specific neutrino of a specific flavor
to
where we actually observe the flavor of
the neutrino
and the energy of the neutrino and then
you know the appearance of disappearance
of an immune neutrino for example if we
start from a beam
of neural neutrinos is a function of the
of the length of the source and this is
shown here
for neutrinos of a specific energy
so you can observe or can try to measure
the disappearance of neural neutrinos
or you can try to find the appearance
of electron neutrinos in the specific
two neutrino model
all right so all we find later is that
we want to
look for disappearance and appearance
from of neutrinos of specific flavors in
order to probe
mass differences
instead of doing this for two
generations we already know how to do
this in three generations we
find that the unitarian matrix has three
angles three rotates rotations
and one complex phase and this looks
very much the same here as in the clock
sector
the big difference is that the values of
those parameters
are quite different for the quarks we
have seen it's dominated by the diagonal
and then we have seen for example in the
wolfenstein parametrization
that we can you know do an expansion of
of the matrix and see
terms which of all of this lambda which
was 0.22 and lambda square and numbers
cubed here in the lepton sector the
situation seems to be quite different
we have a later lecture where we look at
the actual parameters
and the numerical values but what you
see here is that
you know there's more like a democracy
between the
values question is do we have
sensitivity to the complex phase
we can only have that sensitivity if the
value of this matrix element is non-zero
and this has been observed already so
that's good news in order to allow
further neutrino studies so in
in general you can write the oscillation
from one flavor to another flavor state
using this rotational matrix as we have
seen
and with that measure you know the
individual components of the matrix